madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition aux états unis les premiers
sondages sont plutôt favorables à bill
clinton après la publication du rapport
de kenneth starr la maison blanche
contre attaque
la décision surprise en algérie le
président liamine zeroual a annoncé
qu'il quitterait le pouvoir avant la fin
du mois de février lors d'une allocution
radiotélévisée la fête de l'humanité
cette année le rendez-vous de la
majorité plurielle les militants
d'apostrophés dominique strauss kahn
venus débattre de la crise financière
internationale
et puis la mostra de venise à la veille
de son palmarès catherine deneuve
présentait aujourd'hui place vendôme un
film réalisé par nicole garcia avec
jacques godin l'avenir politique de bill
clinton entre les mailles du peuple
américain à elle les premiers sondages
qui ont suivi la publication du rapport
de kenneth starr est plutôt favorable au
chef de l'état la maison blanche prépare
sa riposte de gens le pardon et la
contre attaque juridique une difficile
parade aux accusations de parjure et
d'entravé à la justice
et puis tout à l'heure bill clinton dans
une allocution à la radio est revenu sur
cette semaine épuisante mais s'est dit
déterminé à remplir sa mission
c'est à dire travailler pour le peuple
américain à washington notre
correspondant permanent philippe gassot
ces américains attendent pour acheter
leur exemplaire du rapport car ils le
croient que ce qu'ils touchent et
préfère avoir les preuves en main sans
le filtre des médias
le rapport star et ce soir sur toutes
les lèvres après avoir été sur tous les
ordinateurs du pays est dans tous les
journaux ce matin et cela ne semble pas
avoir fait baisser la cote du président
au contraire elle est passée de 60 %
hier à 62 % aujourd'hui
on est loin de l'effondrement que
certains attendaient hier soir lors de
la première sortie du couple
présidentiel en public après la parution
ça a été l'occasion le parterre était
cher
mais ne nous y trompons pas il reste des
supporters cependant le rapport star ne
prêtent pas à sourire il ne fait pas
dans la dentelle tous les détails
presque minute par minute sont exposés
monica et bill clinton se sont vus dix
fois pas comme on l'a cru dans le bureau
ovale mais dans l'antichambre ou même
parfois dans le cabinet de toilettes
privées du président en répondant qu'il
n'y avait pas eu de rapport stricto
sensu bill clinton se seraient parjure
et par deux fois
selon le procureur il y à 11 bonnes
raisons de destituer le président les
taches sur la robe de monica ne font
aucun doute
elles proviennent les effusions de bill
clinton adn à l'appui le président se
serait livré à des jeux amoureux
largement exposés dans le rapport
leur relation a duré une quinzaine de
mois 48 petits cadeaux ont été échangés
en récupérant les siens bill clinton a
commis selon kenneth starr le délit d'
entrave à la justice
un délit qui est passible de limp agent
de la destitution
certains juristes américains restent
sceptiques
il ya des éléments politiques lourds
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait destitution
pour plusieurs raisons c'est
complètement démesuré oui il y as
plainte pour injures oui il y a plein
pour obstruction à la justice
mais le parjure l'obstruction pour qui
pour quoi
roy le processus va durer des mois
kenneth starr a marqué un point mais la
maison blanche n'est pas prête en rester
là
les avocats de bill clinton ont planché
toute la nuit afin de répondre point par
point aux procureurs lors document sera
déposée dans les heures qui viennent sur
le bureau du congrès l'effet de surprise
ne s'est pas dissipée en algérie 24
heures après que le président zeroual
est annoncé son départ anticipé au plus
tard en février prochain
le pays s'interroge d'autant que le chef
de l'état n'a donné aucune explication
sur les raisons précises de cette
démission annoncée françois gelez
la rumeur courait les rues de la
capitale depuis plusieurs semaines mais
à 20 heures hier soir c'est officiel
liamine zeroual annonce à la télévision
qu'il quittera la présidence de la
république avant la fin de son mandat
élu en novembre 1995 avec 61 % de voix
yamin zeroual aurait dû rester aux
affaires jusqu'à la fin de l'an 2
un départ anticipé que le président n'a
pas expliqué une décision bien souvent
incomprise par la population
cette élection a été donnée subitement
et
on voudrait bien savoir pourquoi sur le
président a été élu par un peuple
président a démissionné des gens c'est
pas vrai et surprise également au sein
des différents partis politiques
algériens
aucun discours à faire ce que vous
personnellement vous avez été surpris
par cette décision
ça fait mal mais je suis un citoyen
comme tous les citoyens algériens
cette année l'action inattendue c'est
une grande surprise
c'était totalement inattendu d'autant
plus que lors de son dernier discours du
20 août dernier il avait réaffirmé sa
détermination et sa volonté de
poursuivre son oeuvre
et là on ne peut se poser que des
questions
al'annonce de cette élection
présidentielle anticipée la presse
algérienne donne plusieurs
interprétations
certains y voient la conséquence d'un
mauvais état de santé du président pour
d'autres c'est le résultat d'une lutte
de clans au sein de l'appareil d'état
certains n'hésitent même pas à parler de
coup d'état maquiller d'autant que cet
homme le plus proche conseiller du
président zeroual le général betchine
est devenu très controversé dans les
cercles du pouvoir
deuxième président a écourté son mandat
après la démission forcée de chadli
bendjedid en 1992 l'algérie entre de
nouveau dans une période d'incertitude
sur fond de crise sociale et de violence
qui à ce jour aurait été plus de 70
mille victimes en france la fête de
l'humanité à la courneuve cette année le
rendez-vous de la majorité plurielle
puisque cet après midi dominique strauss
kahn débattait avec plusieurs dirigeants
communistes sur la crise financière
internationale
les militants ont accueilli parfois
fraîchement souvent vivement le ministre
de l'économie reportage françoise david
jean-pierre testeurs la gauche plurielle
si elle doit exister c'est pas seulement
au gouvernement à l'assemblée
c'est aussi dans le débat dans la
confrontation france parfois un peu rude
et de fait dominique strauss kahn n'a
pas été déçu les militants communistes
juge que la politique du gouvernement de
lionel jospin n'est pas assez social ils
n'ont pas hésité à le dire lors d'un
débat organisé sur la crise financière
mais c'est au stand du ministère des
finances
installé pour la première fois sur la
fête pour promouvoir le rôle que le
dialogue a été le plus animé commence la
gauche c'est amusant non justement c'est
qu'on n'a pas la une des missions de la
gauche c'est tout chacun est libre
le smic est resté pratiquement pareil
excuse pour les ça normal et émouvoir le
monde ou pas c'est pareil l'expliqué a
augmenté de 4% et dernière de plus de
points de vue pour s'installer
la bourse c'est autre chose mais comme
vous le remarquez justement ça va au 3
novembre
les violentes averses qui ont arrosé la
fête toute la journée n'ont pourtant pas
découragé bon nombre de sympathisants et
de militants et les éclaircies ont été
mises à profit pour faire signer la
pétition réclamant notamment une
augmentation du smic
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
situation d'aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin
robert hue demain réuni de nouveaux
adhérents
il aura peut-être quitter ses bottes
mais devra retrousser ses manches pour
faire comprendre à des militants parfois
insatisfaits toute la justesse de sa
stratégie
au canada la deuxième boîte noire de
l'appareil de la suisse air a été
récupéré hier soir par les plongeurs
cette boîte noire contient les
enregistrements des conversations à
l'intérieur du cockpit
elle devrait donner de précieuses
indications aux enquêteurs la première
boîte moi je rappelle s'était avéré
inexploitables il ya trente ans la
caravelle d'air france ajaccio-nice
s'abîmait en mer avec à son bord 95
personnes pour cet anniversaire les
familles des victimes ont assisté à nice
à l'inauguration aujourd'hui d'une stèle
des familles qui réclament toujours des
explications sur les circonstances de
cet accident et sunna farber frédéric
besson
des chants corses pour le recueillement
des familles des 95 victimes de la
caravelle ajaccio-nice dans un jardin de
la promenade des anglais
une sculpture forme edel métallique
rappelle le drame de 1968
si loin si proche aussi console bayat
longtemps mais c'était ce matin c'était
tout à l'heure c'était hier le 11
septembre 1968 à 10h36 la caravelle
explose au large du cap d'antibes à 5
minutes de l'atterrissage le pilote
venait de signaler le feu à bord
le rapport d'expert conclu à un incendie
déclaré à l'arrière de l'appareil
mais les réacteurs dorment toujours à
2000 mètres de fond une pièce manquante
pour ceux qui recherchent la vérité on
recherche surtout de faire remonter les
réacteurs de l'appareil
compte tenu qu'à l'époque il y avait des
manoeuvres en méditerranée des tirs de
missiles et il est possible car missiles
étaient égarés lors de ces tirs et
qu'ils aient eu un impact très important
au niveau du réacteur remonter les
réacteurs les frères paoli demande ce
geste aux autorités trente ans après
l'accident
le dossier a été transmis au ministère
des transports
à l'occasion de la rentrée scolaire
celle des lycées s'est faite jeudi
dernier je vous propose de découvrir à
cal est un établissement unique en son
genre il s'agit d'un lycée 100%
écologique pour le plus grand bonheur
des élèves qui évoque en ce jour de
rentrée la qualité de la vie stéphane
haumant pascal couillaud défi rebora
aquilon ici les noms devant désigne les
classes de seconde c'est poétique et on
aurait presque envie de se mettre au
vert si ce n'était le jour de la rentrée
visite guidée obligatoire avec
l'architecte de ce lycée tout neuf et
100% écologique
pourquoi duchesne parce que dans ce
lycée en avait pratiquement pas le droit
d'employer de voix exotique le respect
de l'environnement est une motivation
forte pour les 1000 élèves déjà inscrits
sans compter la qualité de vie est ce
que c'est vous qui avez choisi de venir
ici
oui pourquoi parce que c'est agréable à
travailler vite et bien
ça vous semble agréable ouais
l'électricité est fournie par une
éolienne et par des panneaux solaires
l'eau de pluie recycler sur coup à la
construction 15% mais les économies
d'énergie diminueront les frais de
fonctionnement d'un tiers chaque année
chantiers propres matériaux recyclables
une véritable petite révolution
culturelle au départ ça semble être
beaucoup de contraintes
et puis c'est vraiment passionnant parce
qu'on emploie des matériaux tout à fait
naturel dont on n'aurait jamais imaginé
qu'on pouvait les employés dans le
bâtiment en cours l'enseignement est
classique filière générale scientifique
technique mais ici l'écologie devrait
très vite devenir une seconde nature
nous avons une petite équipe avec les
professeurs d'histoire géographie de
sciences naturelles la documentaliste
nous envisageons de faire bouger les
élèves de modifier et leurs modalités
leur comportement environnemental pour
les élèves de chimie sera créée une
section traitement de l'eau et la région
nord pas de calais va investir dans de
nouveaux lycées 100% écolo enfin 100 %
pas tout à fait pour l'instant aucun
repas bio n'est prévu à la cantine
cette semaine une décision de justice
marque et le divorce entre la maison
d'édition dargaud et astérix le gaulois
que va-t-il advenir maintenant du héros
de ces bandes dessinées l'enquète de
valérie gas et olivier les mutas c'est
un peu comme si le ciel leur est tombé
sur la tête pour les cinq ans de
salariés français de dargaud la décision
de la cour d'appel de paris
sent le roussi l'éditeur père les droits
d'exploitation des 25 premiers albums
d'astérix c'est à dire plus de 50
millions de francs de recettes annuelles
35% du chiffre d'affaires les
répercussions chez dargaud sont
importantes en termes d'emploi ou
quelques dizaines d'emplois au minimum
seront nécessairement menacées et en
termes de création ou les
et nouvelle série les jeunes auteurs
devront être publiés 40h de parcimonie
par le passé albert uderzo le
dessinateur d'obélix et compagnie
crillon discrètement après huit ans de
zizanie
la justice a donné raison à l'auteur
contre l'éditeur un coup de fer qui met
fin à 38 ans d'une collaboration
fructueuse puisque il s'est vendu 280
millions d'albums à travers le monde
dargaud n'a pas respecté un contrat
important avec des conséquences
importantes sur le plan de l'enjeu
financier n'a pas respecté les gardes
albert uderzo le contrant qui publiera à
l'avenir les premières aventures des
irréductibles gaulois
anne goscinny la fille du scénariste
d'astérix décédé en 77 voulait garder
dargaud comme éditeur mais aux côtés de
son avocat maître jouanno elle se dit
prête à négocier avec albert uderzo
pense que il faut considérer qu astérix
et un enfant un enfant dont les parents
éventuellement on peut voir ça comme ça
sont divorcés et il faut que pour le
bien de l'enfant
on se mettent autour d'une table et
qu'on discute dans quel foyer dans quel
das maintenant va aller l'enfant anne
goscinny n'exclut pas la possibilité de
créer avec uderzo une maison d'édition
pour recueillir l'enfant prodige
les gaulois ne devrait donc pas rester
muet bien longtemps à l'exception d'un
seul chanteur méconnu à l'étranger la
situation catastrophique du bangladesh
depuis plus de deux mois des inondations
ont ravagé ce pays déjà durement
frappées par la pauvreté
ces inondations ont provoqué la mort de
près d'un millier de personnes
et l'on dénombre actuellement 25 million
de sans abri reportage dans la capitale
de nos envoyés spéciaux
gérard gay ce bec et à l'importun
une fois de plus le fleuve a débordé les
fleuves puisqu'il s'agit du gange et du
brahmapoutre qui descend pratiquement de
l'himalaya emportant tout sur son
passage
nous sommes sur le plus grands deltas du
monde qui chaque année dicte sa loi
les trois quarts du bangladesh sont
recouverts par les eaux jamais le pays
n'avait connu un tel déluge
à croire que l'arche de noé s'est échoué
ici et cette année une grande partie de
la capitale est également sous les eaux
alors les embouteillages se sont
déplacés et les habitants de dacca ont
changé de 28 à toute heure de la journée
la ville vit dans une immense paillard
nous n'avons pas de ravitaillement et
nous n'avons plus de transport en fait
nous nous battons pour notre survie et
nous n'avons pas le choix
nissa est responsable d'un atelier de
prêt à porter il nous propose de
l'accompagner pour une visite de son
quartier
ils prennent de l'eau là-bas c'est une
arrivée d'eau en vérité l'eau n'est pas
vraiment potable et l'on craint les
épidémies d'autant qu'il n'est pas rare
de voir des rats flotter à la surface
c'est le lycée le lycée cette famille
vit sur trois ou quatre mètres carrés
depuis deux mois elle ne peut même pas
se déplacer
on ne mange plus du riz du sucre il
c'est dieu qui décide
j'habite ici avec mes ouvriers dans
l'immeuble ils sont près de 700 c'est un
atelier de confection
ici c'est mon usine et comme vous pouvez
le voir ma voiture est bloquée
il ya longtemps que le gouvernement ne
comptabilisent plus les sans abri
certains se sont réfugiés sur les toits
d'autres dans leur malheur ont de la
chance ils ont été regroupés dans des
campements et ont obtenu une aide des
autorités
la distribution du riz sur facebook
surveillance une fois par jour pour les
250 familles réussi la prochaine
bataille de l'eau aura lieu ici où
soufflent en mille personnes sont cernés
depuis des semaines
bien sûr tout pays et mobiliser l'aide
internationale commence à arriver mais
ces inondations catastrophiques souligne
aussi l'incapacité des dirigeants du
pays à maîtriser la démographie
galopante pour empêcher les gens de
s'installer sur les territoires déjà
inondé en cisjordanie près d'une
centaine de palestiniens a été blessée
notamment près de ramallah par des tirs
de soldats israéliens
ces manifestations organisées après
l'assassinât de deux chefs du hamas ont
dégénéré les manifestants ont jeté des
pierres sur les militaires qui ont
répliqué en ouvrant le feu
le bouclage total de la cisjordanie de
la bande de gaza a été maintenu en
allemagne la fièvre monte à 15 jours
maintenant des élections qui opposeront
le champ si la lute coller son
adversaire gerhard schröder ce week end
en bavière les électeurs donneront une
première tendance à travers des
élections régionales un scrutin qui aura
valeur de test à munich olivier lerner
ce n'est pas une brasserie c'est une
réunion politique bière pour tout le
monde à volonté la bavière est riche
très riche mais à munich on ne jette pas
pour autant l'argent par les fenêtres
l'argent gagnaire reste dans les banques
ou dans les voitures
pas forcément argent sociale la face
cachée de munich détruite à 80 % pendant
la guerre on la trouve à 20 minutes du
centre ville c'est hazen bergen des
immeubles gris qui date des années 60
immigration sécurité chômage ici
l'extrême droite a trouvé à qui parler
les émigrés sont trop nombreux nous dit
cet homme et il nous raconte qu'un
étranger a pris l'appartement qui devait
revenir à sa fille à droite toute
tel est l'état d'esprit des dons stober
le ministre président de bavière qui
défend un bilan excellent le train de
vie des bavarois atteint des sommets le
chômage ne dépasse pas la barre des 7%
difficile dans ces conditions pour la
gauche et les verts de proposer une
autre politique sociale mais sur le plan
national
le spd les sociaux-démocrates ont le
vent en poupe
guerra freud r evenus à 30 reprises dans
la région helmut kohl quasi invisible
cette fois seulement 9 millions de
bavarois donneront avec leurs bulletins
de vote
une indication claire sur le nom du
futur chancelier un scrutin très attendu
qui sera analysé à la loupe de m'asseoir
car si la droite se maintient progress
cela aura pour effet de doper la fin de
campagne d'helmut kohl qui en a bien
besoin
si au contraire l'écart se resserre
entre gauche et droite
le chancelier kohl au pouvoir depuis 16
ans maintenant comment sera certainement
à se faire du mauvais sang en france
c'est demain l'ouverture de la chasse
dans 45 départements situés plutôt sud
du pays
la saison s'annonce plutôt bonne pour le
gros gibier pour le lièvre une
information qui devrait satisfaire le
million et demi d'adeptes de la chasse
parmi lesquels se comptent désormais des
femmes elles sont 3000 portrait de l'une
d'elles reportage muriel la saga et
gilbert usant les hommes sans rentrer
d'une chasse au sanglier
ouverte depuis le 15 mars
croire en de la fin il suffisant pascal
elle devra attendre demain pour chasser
le petit gibier
c'est quand même une attente parce que
c'est comme quelqu'un qui fait de la
compétition s'y attend le jour d'un
championnat qu'il a préparée et puisque
bon les chiens c'est une préparation les
fusils sont une autre donc comme
l'appelait son prêt par tout ça cette
jeune femme a décidé de prendre le fusil
il y a un an par amour des animaux
dit-elle pour suivre son ami trop
souvent absents à la saison de la chasse
ces préparatifs à la veille de
l'ouverture ressemblait un peu à une
révision pratiques et théoriques ya deux
sortes foule de cartouches la première
cartouche le 7 le gibier n'est pas trop
loin et leucate c'est comme il est un
peu plus on là il ya les plombs bon un
peu plus loin
les gestes sont encore imprécis
d'ailleurs l'année dernière parce
qu'elle n'a fait qu'une victime un seul
et unique canal la question de dessus et
beaucoup de gibier tout ça c'est en fait
c'est surtout le plaisir d'un il se
promenait l'automne le matin il ya
personne
devant cet engouement féminin les
anciens en arrive à avoir des pensées
bizarre c'est dommage et que ma femme ne
viennent pas chercher de cinglés avec
moi à condition de savoir viser juste et
de garder l'oeil bien ouvert surtout
demain vous êtes généralement nombreux à
prendre la route le week-end la prudence
est de mise surtout sous la pluie les
conducteurs de plus de 65 ans en avec
les très jeunes les plus touchés par les
accidents
c'est pourquoi des stages seniors
organisés partout en france permettent
de faire en deux jours le point de ses
capacités au volant reportage
christophe valant bras philippe ritaine
stop
et oui madame il y avait bien un instant
mais c'est vrai qu'avec tous ces
nouveaux aménagements
la circulation en ville comme ailleurs
c'est plus ce que c'était alors passé la
soixantaine il est parfois bon de
s'adapter aux règles de conduite moderne
c'est le stage seniors de la route
350 francs pour deux jours de remise à
niveau encadrés par des professionnels
il y avait pratiquement tout pour qu'on
me corrige de mes mauvaises habités
comme le signale et vie j'essaie de le
corriger
je croyais que sinon c'est la voiture
qui la voiture qui tournait à priori
thème les enfants ils aborderaient je
croyais qu'on devrait continuer à bien
ces dépenses h puisqu'ils si vous aviez
un panneau cédez le passage
les ont de vrais problèmes et des
problèmes d'insécurité sur les zones à
risque sur les travers ses doigts rapine
l'entrée sortie de voie rapide
d'autoroute des de l'inconfort plus que
de la sécurité dans les aménagements
récents de l'infrastructure en marge de
la conduite sur route et sur piste le
stage comprend une série d'ateliers
sensibilisation aux dangers de l'alcool
au volant
rappel du code de la route ou bilan
visuel et puis il ya ce test de freinage
d'urgence sur simulateur pas toujours
facile
d'année en année les seniors
représentent une plus large part de la
population française et donc des
conducteurs ils sont parmi les plus
touchés par les accidents
ici on se remet en confiance pas je
pense d'après laisse que j'ai les tests
j'ai passé ce matin je ne suis pas un
producteur dangereux depuis sa mise en
place en début d'année le stage a déjà
accueilli plus de 800 seniors de la roue
au castellet dans le var le bol d'or le
rendez-vous annuel des motards portage
jacques cardoze vincent deux ombres ce
n'est pas encore la longue ligne droite
du mistral
ni le double virage du beausset pourtant
la course a déjà commencé car la montée
vers le circuit du castellet figurent
parmi les attractions du week end pour
80 mille motards sorte de course avant
la course qui parfois prend des allures
de chemin de croix
j'arrive assez long celui la trêve je le
mets au moins galère ou pas galère c'est
cool quoi on a plusieurs que roland ries
car on avant chaque tour on essaie de
ses fans et comme on peut à l'économie
après le reste on verra bien dérapages
contrôlés risques calculés
la fête est lancé et pendant ce temps
les mécaniciens s'affairent ceux là sont
bénévoles
ils sont 20 font vivre l'une des plus
petites équipes parmi les 70 engagés
c'est ça aussi le bol d'or des amoureux
de la moto l'année passée vice-champion
d'europe aujourd'hui dans la difficulté
on n'a pas de budget c'est l'argent
personnel des pilotes
on est soutenu par un concessionnaire de
rennes qui est très sympa avec nous mais
le bol on espère bien faire quelque
chose et sauver la saison rien à voir
avec la star des paddocks jean-michel
bas il pilote de vitesse s'est offert
exceptionnellement un week-end en
endurance moto dans ses limites
donc forcément c'est ça le plus facile
du côté mental par tendre condition
physique ça va être très dur toute la
nuit à tenir et c'est parti pour 24
heures de piste 24 heures d'efforts pour
des pilotes qui se relaieront jusqu'au
bout de la nuit
quant aux spectateurs certains ont
préféré prendre les devants
histoire de ne rien rater
de la nuit qui s'annonce
cinéma avec ce soir à deauville la
présentation du film le masque de zorro
avec antonio banderas dans le rôle du
justicier masqué nicolas cornu langlois
zorro est arrivé ici à l'idée et
catherine zeta-jones connaît bien soros
et son fougueux partenaires voici donc
antonio banderas accompagné de sa femme
mélanie griffiths venus ensemble pour
présenter le masque de zorro une
production de steven spielberg
une nouvelle version qui renoue avec les
grandes épopées hollywoodienne et les
grands thèmes romantiques
un zorro ravivées par le charisme et
l'humour du belle andalouse et pour vous
qui est zorro oui c'est une légende
celle de don diego de la vega
adversaires de l'oppression espagnol qui
transmet son savoir aux jeunes rebelles
leçon numéro 1 ne jamais attaquer dans
la colère leçon numéro deux vient avec
moi il ne joue pas sur la force mais sur
la ruse et la délicatesse il a les
bonnes manières avec les femmes et les
plutôt drôle
c'était génial ce combat allait bien
au-delà d'un jeu d'acteur c'était une
belle performance
c'était un jeu d'amour et de séduction
et c'est le ton général de ce film qui a
enflammé le tout festival et laissé des
traces d'estocade sur deauville
la mostra de venise à la veille du
palmarès avec aujourd'hui l'un des
derniers films présentés en compétition
place vendôme de nicole garcia avec
notamment catherine deneuve et jacques
dutronc le festival sous la pluie pour
cette dernière journée accueilli et
warren beatty et robert de niro
reportage pascal deschamps frédéric
bonnet pour son avant-dernier jour
lamastre ans s'est offert un bon orage
une fois n'est pas coutume et une pluie
des toiles parfois filantes comme ici
robert de niro accompagné de toute
l'équipe de ronin présenté en
compétition le film qu'il a tourné à
paris l'hiver dernier avec jean reno en
lice pour un lion d'or ou un prix
d'interprétation
l'acteur-réalisateur américain de blue
earth ou satire explosive de la vie
politique américaine
point n betty et catherine deneuve en
tournage à paris l'actrice française a
fait dans la nuit le voyage à venise en
coup de vent pour y présenter le
troisième film de nicole garcia place
vendôme elle y internet marianne mariée
à un riche diamantaire femme dépressive
et alcoolique à la recherche de son
équilibre
un nouveau défi pour l'actrice souvent
on me dit sam et dean et vous prenez des
risques quand j'ai tourné je ne sais pas
avec qui oui avec voleurs ou raoul ruiz
ou dit prenez un risque mais moi je dis
toujours et je fais je pense vraiment je
pense que vraiment s'il n'y a pas de
risques parce qu'on appelle les risques
en vérité ce sont des chances
une histoire triste et vraiment ça
dépendront de la rencontre face aux
curieux je les ai toujours demandé
comment bien dit tier récupérateur
récupérateurs que tu joues mieux qu'un
bon je sais pas boire une partition
subtile écrite spécialement pour elle
par nicole garcia qu'elle a servie
admirablement moi je vais faire une
grande confiance j'essaie que savait
qu'elle était vraiment porté par par ce
sujet et par ce personnage féminin
et comme c'est une actrice aussi et je
savais que c'était vraiment quelque
chose qu'elle ressentait très
profondément
et c'est vrai que c'est un c'est un
échange joué depuis quelques années la
mostra réussi aux actrices françaises
qu'en six ans juliette binoche sandrine
bonnaire et isabelle huppert et fut
récompensé le nom de catherine deneuve
était aujourd'hui à venir
l'un des plus murmurer pour un prix
d'interprétation la fin de cette édition
voici le rappel des titres aux
etats-unis les premiers sondages sont
plutôt favorables à bill clinton après
la publication sur internet et dans la
presse du rapport de kenneth starr
la décision surprise en algérie le
président liamine zeroual a annoncé
qu'il quitterait le pouvoir avant la fin
du mois de février lors d'une allocution
radiotélévisée pour un instant le
rappelle météo présentée par nathalie
rihouet 20h55 tapis rouge au casino de
paris
la rentrée de michel drucker avec une
affiche exceptionnelle pour cette
nouvelle émission
céline dion michel sardou florent pagny
lara fabian thierry lhermitte et
d'autres demain matin dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra michèle
demessine secrétaire d'état au tourisme
je vous retrouve dès 13h merci de votre
attention excellente fin de soirée
secondes